[Music]
hi I'm Isabella Boyston and I'm a
principal dancer at American Ballet
[Music]
[Applause]
Theater little violin
action
well yeah I mean I think they achieved
their goal of creating a Fusion Dance I
saw some like coffee grinders like
Ballroom Little Jazz chass a cabriel
which was a ballet move that's when you
like jump up and like beat your legs
together in the air the coffee grinder
you're like down on the ground and then
you like send your leg around and like
jump over your own leg basically it is
actually really common for us to dance
and heels what's amazing about ballet is
gives you such crazy control of your
body so I think that makes us pretty
versatile basically like you'll just
rehearse in whatever you're going to
wear this is a ptaa where there's two
people dancing together like a duet
basically when you're really synced up
with somebody it's like the best feeling
ever I would say chemistry is very
important it's also something that you
can fake because you're a professional
you know you just have to work a little
harder I guess one thing that also helps
is like time with a partnership I've
noticed there are dancers now that I've
been paired with for like 10 years and
that's amazing cuz you get so
comfortable with each other it just
becomes really
[Music]
intuitive and 1 2 3 4 5 6 my
God it seems a little high budget for
most dance acmy it's just very like
Hollywood and they used top level
dancers so the dance scenes are really
well executed so good I mean yeah that
dancer Ethan steel Hooper neelen in the
movie he's like one of my all-time
favorite dancers him and Sasha rety also
Charlie they're both just phenomenal
dancers super fun to
watch oh my God the tutu
reveal that's amazing it's pretty
typical like a lot of ballets have
costume change elements that happen
either on stage or off stage but yeah
ter away 2 two that that really is
[Music]
Iconic that's called a buet when you go
up on point and you your feet are like
shimmering ing it's a staple of
Classical Ballet makes it look like
you're like skimming the floor and like
floating it's very ethereal they appear
to be classically trained ballet dancers
the choreography is definitely
incorporating like modern and Jazz
ballet has very shaped positions of the
arms like how many are there 1 2 3 4
five basically everything that we do in
ballet you're always going through those
positions they're not doing like
traditional ballet positions those women
are not wearing point shoes they're just
wearing flat shoes the like more
featured ones are on point I've worn
flat shoes for more contemporary ballet
especially like the ju toos of the more
like classical movements in front and
then the more modern group dance in the
back ballet is really edgy in that it's
extreme physical expression of emotions
and music the virtuosity of ballet when
combined with another virtuosic artist
it's a really good match especially when
you know they get real ballet dancers to
do
[Music]
it can I start
again I think that's kind of unlikely
they don't really have time for you to
be like starting over again you kind of
just get that one shot and really hope
you're on that
day oh they're
[Music]
bored so
Fierce I mean so iconic this looks like
jazz ballet is this is definitely not
like strictly ballet like warmers are
not just a cliche we wear them all the
time in order to like not get injured
you have to be so warm all the time and
so that's why we wear so many layers
also love the director or whoever is
smoking a cigar in the studio can't do
that
[Music]
anymore
what she's doing right now that's called
a p man you're pushing off of your left
leg and you do I don't know so many PKS
by the end of the Black Swan ptaa you
like cannot feel your left calf cuz
everything's just on that leg they did
an amazing job researching the dance
elements the ballet is called Swan Lake
in the ballet the same ballerina plays
two different characters which is it's
so fun cuz it's this dual role you have
the white swan Odette who's very like
pure and passionate and Soulful and then
you get to play the Black Swan later in
the ballet who's like super flashy and
sexy and evil and does these incredible
virtuosic Feats so yeah it's like the
ultimate challenge for a ballerina to
play the two roles music's amazing
hovsky
so this music is the music for the Cod
of Black Swan where you do the like
iconic 32 Fates which is like you stay
on that one leg and do 32 revolutions I
think Swan Lake is still my hardest
ballet it's a career-long journey
actually the Natalie's dance Double is a
Dancer with American Ballet Theater as
well Sarah Lane I think you can tell
that Natalie did do a lot of work to
study ballet and get in shape and get
into the psyche of a dancer but yeah you
can definitely tell when it is Sarah the
double dancing it would be super
annoying to dance with wings on your
arms it also make the partnering like
impossible you'd be like slapping your
partner with a wing we wear like a tutu
that has feather inspired and like
feather is things on your head in ballet
I love to see like the body ballet is
all about like lines you want to have
like long extended lines and you don't
want anything to be cutting and breaking
your line in Swan Lake there's like a
special technique that you have to work
on with your arms where you emulate the
swan with your actual arms I think black
Swan's an amazing horror film and it's a
fantasy it's not a documentary about
what it's like to be a dancer it's not
that interesting to watch the movie
about the like happy well-adjusted
ballet dancer it's more interesting to
watch a movie about oh you know someone
who's like falling apart or unhinged
it's important to remember that ballet
dancers are world class athletes and in
order to do that like you you have to
just like take care of
[Music]
yourself oh I know that dancer from
Instagram I've seen like water on stage
before it looks like it was inspired by
a dance film that I saw from a few years
ago a similar wet look it's a lot more
like grounded a lot more P which is bent
legs into the ground yeah you can tell
that Kylie's I mean she has beautiful
lines super impressive that he's not a
dancer he definitely looks like it he's
ripped looks like he's been working out
the partnering mainly involves her using
his body to hold her own weight up so
the partnering is almost more coming
from her which probably made it easier
for him to execute as not a professional
dancer but it's looks really good makes
ballet more accessible to like a new
audience and obviously they use a
professional dancer and made something
really
[Music]
beautiful I
can't oh is did Carly Ray jeffson do the
music I am obsessed with
Carly
oh my God I love this
song they wanted to cut to the feeling
in the
1880s that really is my girlfriend
that's what my husband says when I'm up
there yes
layout that was really cute I'm feeling
the white tights with the red shoes very
festive those animated ballerinas had
major style they were really like
bending with their bodies and like
leaving their head back just very
full-bodied movement not stiff and rigid
they must have based that off of a real
dancer I would imagine they're really
flexible too like more than me I love to
see that when I go to a performance and
um I think they definitely captured that
must have been the inspiration from
Carly and at the time of the 19th
century I would think ballet was purely
the classical music I think nowadays
people are used to seeing like ballet to
pop music or
[Music]
anything it's definitely modern dance
it's not Classical Ballet but I think a
lot of modern dance techniques like
there is like a real classical rigor to
that training so yeah it might look
casual or AB ract but there's actually
so much training that went into that as
well it looks to me as though they had a
dance Double for her for some of them
like this solo I don't think someone who
wasn't trained for many years in dance
could execute it like that you can't
become a concert pianist in 6 months so
why would you think that you could
become a classical ballerina in 6 months
when you know we've been training our
whole lives for this and it's still hard
for us one thing also
that I related to in this movie was the
dancers pushing themselves to the brink
I do shows and it is just sheer
willpower to get through it basically
the curtains come down and then I've
been like throwing up in the trash on
the side from exertion stuff I've
rehearsed a ton is still even for the
best dancers in the world it is a true
challenge to get through the classics
the choreographer did a really good job
making really like hard shapes to kind
of depict that aggressive of
Witchcraft what I did like about
susperia was the idea of how dancing
could be used to like cast a spell or
like invoke power cuz I think that is
definitely something I've experienced
and you know when you really find your
flow in a performance um it feels like
tapping into something like a greater
power I loved that and then it got real
weird I think they did a great job they
obviously like did their research and
were very
[Music]
respectful yeah so I was actually
Jennifer Lawrence's dance Double in the
movie Red Sparrow that's my dancing so
this is like on YouTube now I haven't
seen this since like the movie came
out oh my my God it's so nasty oh this
was inspired by the firebird which is a
great ballet and a role that I've done a
lot and the music is by Stravinsky it's
a Russian folk tale and it's about a the
firebird is a mythical creature
basically ends up like giving a feather
to this guy that she meets in the forest
you can see I do like fluttering hand
movements that I think evoke bird
imagery one move that you can see is
called an Trisha which is where you jump
up and you beat your feet you jump It's
like a fluttering move with your feet
that's an Arabesque it's a very famous
ballet move it's when you like lift your
back leg I mean it's more technical than
that but
[__] that's a
grand you could do it partnered like
there it's a partnered gr Jennifer
Lawrence did like train for a few months
um and she basically had to like learn
the choreography we would alternate
takes so I would do it and then she
would go just to have her arms and head
like in the positions where they needed
to be she definitely had to like go
outside of her comfort zone but she like
took it all in stride and was super fun
to work with that is
grotesque so they had a prosthetic leg
both of us did that shot to just
seamlessly get it all it's literally
every dancer's worst nightmare so yeah
it definitely made me a little squeamish
I have never heard that happening in a
show I have seen some pretty
heartwrenching injuries go down in stage
I've seen people tear their ACL I've
seen calf tears subluxed knee shoulder
blown out ankle ligaments it's more
common for dancers to have overuse
injuries dancers are really bad at
taking time off when they need to it was
really fun seeing like the making of a
movie the two was so beautiful I had
like three brand new tutus in case
anything happened to the one the costume
budget was a little different than what
we're working with at the ballet the
discipline that you need to be a dancer
would probably serve you really well as
a spy I'm not a spy not yet maybe when I
retire career transitions for dancers